bonjour Et si on lançait un moustique
depuis Paris pour toucher une balle de
golf à Moscou et qu'elle fasse 5 fois le
et qu'il fasse cinq fois le tour de la
terre avant de frapper sa cible c'est un
peu ce qui s'est passé cette nuit avec
un satellite qui a travaillé sur un
astéroïde bonjour Tristan
au Figaro vous allez à paternité de
cette comparaison on va dire oui est-ce
qu'on peut vous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé cette nuit on va montrer ces
images ces images qui sont assez
impressionnantes la NASA a envoyé un
Asté un satellite un satellite pour
toucher un astéroïde pour le faire
dévier de sa trajectoire c'est ça c'est
ça alors on parle plutôt de sonde
planétaire ou de vaisseaux spatial
quand pour ce type de mission
d'exploration mais oui c'est l'idée en
gros ils envoyaient un vaisseau qui
s'appelle dart donc pour double
astéroïde redirection
impact mais c'est pas impact donc et sur
trajectory et surtout d'art ça veut dire
fléchettes Dar ça veut dire fléchettes
en anglais donc et donc l'idée c'est de
m'envoyer ce vaisseau sur un petit
astéroïde pour le essayer de voir si on
arrivait à le dévier de cette
trajectoire
alors évidemment c'est pas un astéroïde
qui menace la Terre on pourrait y
revenir l'idée c'était juste voilà de
voir si
l'humanité était capable de dévier un
essaie de trajectoire si un jour par
hasard on arrivait à détecter
suffisamment en avance un astéroïde qui
se dirige vers nous et qui présente un
danger de de voir si on serait capable
de faire quelque chose pour éviter la
catastrophe donc là c'est une c'est une
phase de test on va dire pour plus tard
pour au cas où un jour on a un énorme
Story qui arrive on lui enverra ce titre
dessus pour le faire dévier ça rappelle
quand même quelques petits films oui
bien sûr ben c'est forcément
c'est un sujet qui a longtemps été pris
un peu à la légère par les
par les agences spatiales et manière
générale par le les politiques aussi
derrière
c'est un peu changé avec la météorite de
Chelia binz que je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez en Russie et une météorite qui
qui rentrait dans le ciel et qui a
explosé à peine de mètres du sol ça a
fait
exploser toutes les fenêtres de de la
vie ça a fait un bruit incroyable et
c'était un tout petit astéroïde et c'est
en quelques mètres c'était je crois en
2012-2011
j'ai un trou noir mais je voulais
peut-être 2011 ou 2012 bon on peut
vérifier et
du coup bah voilà là tout le monde a
commencé à comprendre que en fait cette
menace
astéroïde dont parle dont parler une
communauté on va dire des des
spécialistes des astéroïdes c'était pas
simplement jouer à se faire peur c'était
quand même une menace réelle c'est pas
une menace
on va dire imminente
même si on connaît pas forcément la
position de beaucoup d'astéroïdes de
quelques dizaines de mètres qui
pourraient représenter quand même une
menace pour locale on va dire
mais
voilà c'est un danger qui est grand le
risque est faible mais ça va se produire
un jour alors un jour est-ce que c'est
un jour dans 10000 ans
demain ou dans Ça c'est c'est difficile
à dire mais quand vous regardez la Lune
par exemple vous voyez qu'elle est
criblée d'impact il y a un certain
nombre de ces impacts qui sont entre
guillemets récents leur récent de temps
géologique c'est pas encore une fois pas
hier mais voilà il faut pas oublier que
ce qui a fait disparaître les dinosaures
c'est l'impact d'un astéroïde
c'était il y a sens il y a 66 millions
d'années ça peut paraître loin
à notre échelle l'humanité apparu après
1,5 millions d'années en comptant large
on va dire les premiers les premiers
le premier les premiers hominidés
mais voilà ça peut ça peut ça peut se
reproduire les les probabilités d'impact
sont loin d'être nuls nuls et surtout
voilà il y a plein plein de petits
cordes qui ne connaît pas la position
l'idée c'est ça c'est de c'est de faire
un test grandeur nature parce qu'en fait
on pourrait y revenir et on ça peut
paraître simple comme ça on vous dites
peut-être ben voilà je sais pas c'est
comme si j'ai envoyé une petite bille
sur une grosse boule de pétanque voilà
on peut facilement ce café mais en fait
pas du tout on est dans on est dans un
environnement de micro gravité ou en
fait la le les choses ne se comportent
pas du tout du tout du tout de la même
manière on y reviendra peut-être on
n'aura pas les choses droites en fait il
faut les envoyer
ça c'est pour le viser donc ça c'est la
première étape est-ce qu'on a est-ce
qu'on arrivera à le toucher
et là ça a été un succès total de la
NASA donc ça c'est la logique je prenais
le vaisseau est pas très gros il fait
prêt le corps du vaisseau fait un mètre
à peu près 1 m3 c'est c'est
une grosse machine à laver une petite
voiture une petite voiture et de golf
une petite Smart vous prenez un peu
l'image que vous voulez peu importe
c'est ça vous donne de l'ordre de
grandeur l'astéroïde lui fait qu'on
visait fait 150 mètres de diamètre
environ donc c'est pas très grand c'est
la moitié de la Tour Eiffel donc faut
envoyer ça et donc là l'astéroïde
actuellement se situe à 11 millions de
kilomètres de la Terre ça ferait 28 fois
mettons 30 fois la distance Terre-Lune
donc c'est assez loin et en plus pour y
arriver comme dans l'espace donc le le
vaisseau a décollé depuis la Terre il a
il a rattrapé l'astéroïde dans sa
construction du soleil et au final le
vaisseau a fait quasiment un tour du
soleil complet avant d'arriver sur sa
cible et de le percuter une cible fait
150 m dans l'espace complètement envie
de passer assez c'est incroyable il faut
voir que c'était astéroïde double donc
c'est un astéroïde double il y a deux
corps il y a dix mots ce qui est le
corps principal qui fait 800 mètres et
le petit qui fait 150 mètres qui est à
côté ou alors on le voit sur ces images
alors là on voit on le voit s'écraser
sur le petit mais il passe alors
attendez c'est pas ces images là c'est
celui-là voilà c'est les images
comment on arrive à avoir des images là
là on a le gros astéroïde à gauche on
passe à côté et on va s'écraser sur le
petit et donc surtout ça se fait toute
la navigation finale donc il faut être
extrêmement précis on connaît la
puissance de la sonde à quelques à
quelques dizaines de mètres près dans
l'espace grâce aux antennes qu'on a au
sol enfin c'est c'est assez hurissant on
connaît sa vitesse à quelques
millimètres par seconde près alors
qu'elle se situe 11 millions de
kilomètres et donc il a fallu déjà
commencé par viser cette astéroïde il
faut savoir que depuis la Terre on le on
le on le voit pas l'œil nu déjà ça
stéroïde évidemment on le voit avec des
télescopes mais on est capable de voir
que un point de lumière on distingue pas
du tout la lune on peut pas résoudre la
lune les deux nous apparaissent comme un
seul point lumineux et c'est juste par
les variations de luminosité de ce point
de lumière qu'on a déduit avant avant le
lancement de la mission que c'était deux
thyroïdes et dont on a estimé leur
taille à travers juste une courbe de
lumière on voit un point lumineux on
étudie comment sa luminosité Paris et
après on fait des modèles on arrive à
déjà ça en soit je trouve ça assez
fantastique et donc on avait jamais vu
cette lune quelque part on c'est un peu
faux les sourcils qui étaient convaincus
qu'il y avait une lune mais quelque part
on savait pas c'est une lune on l'avait
on l'avait jamais vu
avec des avec des calculs mais on
l'avait pas vu de de par les courbes de
lumière dont on sait que voilà c'est on
les interprète c'est variations
luminosité comme le passage d'une lune
devant son corps par an mais voilà on
l'avait jamais vu et donc hier jusqu'à
60 minutes avant l'impact
on avait voilà on n'avait jamais vu
cette lune et donc là 60 minutes on
voyait deux points on commence à avoir
apparaître un point très très tenu à
côté de ce point un peu plus lumineux et
petit à petit voilà c'était après cette
image là ça ça doit être une demi-heure
avant l'impact donc 30 minutes avant
l'impact on voit juste vraiment un point
de lumière pour le pour le premier
astéroïde un autre point là c'est très
accéléré ça en stop c'est un stop motion
là toute cette phase d'arrivée qu'on
voit prend après après une demi-heure
donc on se rapproche doucement et c'est
vraiment que dans cette dernière
demi-heure on voit le monde apparaître
et ça c'était fantastique de voir ce
monde apparaître on n'a jamais vu quoi
de voir ses rochers et là de voir la
surface de l'astéroïde avec toutes ces
toutes ces cailloux de différentes
tailles cette surface qu'on s'est
laissée oh c'est nourrissant quoi le on
en reparlera peut-être mais la forme de
la story de principale et assez
étonnante alors c'est d'être lié à des
jeux de lumière et d'orientation
la Lune est manière assez surprenante
exactement conforme à ce qu'on imaginait
ces espèces de une espèce de solide fait
de plein de cailloux
et voilà donc ça c'est fascinant hier on
a découvert vraiment en arrivant un
monde et donc là on voit la sonde qui
arrive sur la Lune en plein milieu
et la percuté vraiment en plein centre
exactement comme prévu
autre chose fantastique ça a donné lieu
à un panache de poussière qu'on a pu
voir depuis le sol donc tout à l'heure
qu'on arrivait pas à distinguer la Lune
depuis le sol là on le voit sur cette
image là donc c'est la collaboration
Atlas je crois que c'est un télescope
qui est situé à Hawaii je crois
donc là on voit l'astéroïde
essentiellement des guimauze donc le le
corps par an quoi un point de lumière on
voit pas on voit pas la on n'est pas cap
de discerner la lune mais on voit cette
espèce de nuage de poussière qui est
émis par l'impact de la sonde sur la
lune on sait pas du tout ce que ça
donnait comme cratère encore on sait pas
du tout
j'ai pas encore réussi à avoir de de
de spécialistes ce matin pour me
commenter justement ces images d'Atlas
qui sont sorties vraiment
à des traversées
mais je suis fasciné par le l'ampleur du
du panache de fumée je me demande ce que
ça veut dire exactement dans quel sens
ça a frapper voilà comme ça il me semble
que la sonde elle est quand même dans le
plutôt dans le sens de l'astéroïde donc
elle est arrivée par la droite et donc
je me serais attendu avoir un voilà par
pareil avec notre échec terrestre quoi
je me serais attendu à voir un un
panache du côté où la sonde est rentrées
on a l'impression que c'est de l'autre
côté alors soit c'est le peut-être c'est
une une
la vue qui me qui nous qui nous perturbe
je sais pas il faut que je j'en parle en
tout cas incroyable c'est l'ampleur du
nuage qu'on te regarde alors que la lune
elle est pas visible c'est c'est facile
le nuage fait plus que la taille de de
ce qu'on voit regardez voilà on a
d'avoir quelque chose d'avoir fait
exploser quelque chose à faire exploser
la lune quoi alors je pense pas que ce
soit le cas mais en tout cas
bon alors qu'est-ce qui ce qui il y a un
petit satellite italien qui s'appelle
l'échec cube qui était qui avait été
largué par la sonde un peu avant
d'arriver deux semaines avant son
arrivée et qui devait prendre des images
alors au moment de l'impact puis
survoler quelques minutes après l'impact
le cratère on n'a pas eu de nouvelles de
l'échec cube à ma connaissance quand on
voit la violence de l'éjecta je
j'espère que la sonde n'a pas été
percutée qu'elle a pu
elle devait prendre des images et
ensuite ça lui prenait un peu de temps
pour les transmettre la sonde elle
pouvait le faire en temps réel avec une
grosse centaine qui lui permettait
d'envoyer un gros débit d'information le
petit Lichia cube lui et pas du tout
équipé des mêmes moyens et donc du coup
bah voilà il a un débit de vous imaginez
des connexions Internet 56k par rapport
à à
on voit ces images et on sait d'image on
les avions direct c'est à dire qu'en
fait on est capable de diffuser mais en
France on imagine on le savait mais de
diffuser des images comme ça
alors on a eu un petit on a eu un petit
aperçu avec l'atterrissage du rover
persévérance récemment on avait pu dans
les minutes qui avait suivi
l'atterrissage disposé d'un film du
rover qui se faisait la surface qui en
avait pas encore jamais jamais fait et
moi-même j'avais été surpris parce que
on sentait avoir des images de
définition mais pas aussi vite pas
autant voilà le le le le les
technologies quand même on évolué à ce
niveau là et là c'est voilà c'est une
sonde qui est alors elle est pas très
loin de nous de kilomètres c'est 38
secondes lumière donc c'est à dire que
le signal met 38 secondes à nous arriver
c'est beaucoup plus rapide par exemple
que que Mars où il y a un décalage de
plusieurs minutes
mais voilà c'est quand même assez
facilement c'est pas un énorme satellite
un cube et donc voilà il arrivait à nous
envoyer des des images c'était ouais
c'était quasiment un film quoi je sais
pas quel était le taux de
rafraîchissement des des images
exactement mais il y en avait il y en
avait clairement beaucoup quand on avait
l'impression vraiment de de
d'être en live quoi de suivre de suivre
et puis et puis tu te rapporte la sonde
cheval sur la sonde effectivement ils
avaient des devoirs avec un niveau de
détails assez impressionnant tout à
l'heure le le seul de cette de cette
astéroïde qu'on a touché on voit très
précisément de quoi il est fait des
rochers c'est assez impressionnant aussi
sur la dernière image qui a été prise
donc c'est quelques secondes avant
l'impact c'est 2 secondes il est arrivé
à envoyer une une image deux secondes
avant de percut avant de le percuter
donc faut passer du temps réel quoi
c'est c'est YouTube quoi enfin je c'est
quand même c'est quand même assez assez
dingue et la résolution est de 9 cm je
crois par pixel
voilà c'est c'est fantastique quoi c'est
une meilleure résolution que Google
Earth quoi
et donc on a envoyé donc ce satellite de
ça fait 500 kg c'est ça oui puis il
faisait un peu peut-être 600 kg au
départ et il avait un peu de d'ergol
avec lui consommables il fait 550 kg je
crois quand il devait percuter
l'astéroïde pas de bêtises c'est pas
très gros hein le j'ai oublié la masse
exacte de la lune mais ça se compte je
crois en millions de tonnes
donc évidemment le le rapport
le rapport de
de poids évidemment est assez j'ai
comparé un moustique et une balle de
golf c'était en termes de taille et pas
en terme de masse mais quelque part
on doit avoir on doit être sur quelque
chose de d'un peu approchant voire même
peut-être de de
différence plus grande encore pour
l'instant entre l'astéroïde et la masse
de et donc voilà on sait pas du tout en
fait comment cette astéroïde
va réagir
ce qu'on sait c'est que ça représente
pas de danger
pour la terre parce que l'astéroïde
passe c'est un astéroïde qui passe
proche de la Terre donc dans une km mais
pas dangereusement proche et on n'a pas
percuté la story de principale justement
mais sa lune
dans l'idée que voilà en touchant la
Lune a priori on a aucune chance de
dévier le son corp parent de manière
notable et ce qu'on espère c'est qu'en
fait comme la lune tourne autour de son
astéroïde en à peu près 12 heures on
arrive à induire une petite une petite
des légions de trajectoire qui va être
très légèrement ralentir le le la course
de la Lune autour de son auto
sanastrique par an et donc on va mesurer
la période depuis la Terre donc les
cours de l'Université je vous parlais
tout à l'heure pour mesurer donc ça va
prendre un peu de temps parce qu'il va
falloir multiplier les passages pour
arriver à déceler les quelques minutes
quelques secondes de différence qu'il y
a par rapport
à avant l'impact alors après quand on
voit ce nuage de
ce nuage qui expulsé je vous avoue que
je je
me demande si la la déviation va pas
être plus importante que prévu pour la
lune est-ce que est-ce que c'est
possible de le détruire grâce à ça alors
le détruire il y a aucun modèle avant
qui prévoyait sa destruction l'impact
est quand même super violent à la cendre
elle part elle est elle elle va la
vitesse relative c'est 22000 km/h
donc ça va vite
c'est à dire qu'on pouvait faire 22000
km en une heure c'est un peu une
tautologie de dire ça mais ça ça permet
de d'enquidé donc faire la moitié du
Tour de le de la terre en une heure donc
ça va quand même très vite et
la somme fait 500 kg donc c'est quand
même voilà c'est 500 kg c'est c'est un
beau corps
c'est une petite voiture est sans permis
on va dire
qui a envoyé à 22000 km/h dans un
quelque chose qui est pas non plus
gigantesque quoi qu'il fait 160 mètres
de diamètre c'est la moitié de la de la
Tour Eiffel c'est pas de bêtises oui
c'est 300 m de la Tour Eiffel donc ça va
être la moitié de la Tour Eiffel à peu
près prenez un gros cube ou le poser à
côté de la tour Eiffel il faut qu'il
arrive après la moitié de la Tour Eiffel
et donc vous envoyer là-dessus une une
petite voiture être sans permis très
puissante donc là comme ça on se dit bon
ben un gros caillou une montagne une
voiturette bon on va pas non plus le
détruire mais là il faut s'imaginer que
c'est un corps qui est très faiblement
cohésif c'est un astéroïde donc la
gravité à la surface de la survie de la
cohésion la force qui si vous voulez le
l'astéroïde c'est une feuille de papier
moins qu'une feuille de papier sur ma
main vous voyez le
tout peut s'envoler on peut dire assez
rapidement en fait la cohésion est très
peu assurée donc ce que les et c'était
une des choses qu'on connaît les
scientifiques voulaient regarder ils se
disent que voilà donc il y a cette
espèce d'agrégat de cailloux
dimorphos c'est assez conforme à ce
qu'on imaginait ça qu'on pense qu'en
gros quand didimo s'est formé il
tournait très vite sur lui-même ça agit
de la matière autour de lui qui s'est
réamalgamé pour former cette cette
petite lune donc on pense que c'est un
amas peu cohésif quoi fait de plein de
cailloux et de poussière qui tiennent
ensemble mais voilà on souffle dessus
vraiment ça s'envole on l'a vu avec deux
missions qui sont les astéroïdes
récemment les historiques bénoud et les
stories au goût ces deux missions une
émission américaine japonaise ayabusa
une mission américaine
Osiris Rex et on a vu que quand elles
sont il y en a une qui a envoyé une
petite bille d'acier là sur à la surface
assez fort un tiers de pistolet si vous
voulez ça ça a vraiment vaporisé des
milliers de cailloux on s'attendait pas
du tout est-ce que ce soit aussi violent
Osiris Rex non c'est une des deux sons
c'est approché très très près il a été
mise en danger par juste le le le la
propulseur ont envoyé des des poussières
ça
alors c'est des propulseurs vraiment
très très faible quoi c'est comme si je
je soufflais un peu fort
ça ça voilà si donc faut s'imaginer ce
espèce de d'amalgame et donc on tape
dedans très fort et donc ils ont dit ce
qui craignent c'est qu'en gros bah la
sonde elle rentre là-dedans un peu comme
dans un comme dans un tas de sable si
vous voulez et que du coup ça ça
l'englobe du coup ça la récupère
exactement c'est ça qu'elle va se
détruire mais c'est ça la voilà que ça
ça
disciple complètement toute l'énergie de
de l'impact et qui finalement on dévie
très peu l'astéroïde
en cas de choc serait comme on pourrait
le dire
encaisser par l'astéroïde exactement
imaginez imaginez un
coussin plein de billes de polystyrène
un fat boy il a plein de poules de de
polystyrène on va vous l'ouvrez vous
lancer une balle très forte dedans elle
va être aspirée à cette différence que
l'on est en micro gravité et que du coup
ben on quand on lance ça et que les
petits grains de polystyrène ils sont
perturbés et là du coup sur l'image et
ben ça a donné lieu à un panache de
fumée comme incroyable et donc du coup
ben voilà on se demande à quoi ressemble
le cratère voilà alors il y a une
mission européenne qui aurait dû arriver
avant la mission américaine et qui
aurait pu donc caractériser les
astéroïdes à l'avance observer l'impact
le nuage le cratère etc
malheureusement
l'Europe et en particulier l'Allemagne
on renoncé à son financement c'était je
crois en 2013 ou en 2014
[Musique]
et du coup la mission a été
mis en suspend bien suspens annulé même
en disant clairement elle a été annulée
et et les Américains ont finalement
décidé d'y aller tout seul
et ce n'est qu'après après ça que
finalement les en 2018 sous l'impulsion
notamment du directeur d'agence spatiale
européenne allemand il y a une Verner
qui a décidé de remettre la mission sur
les rails alors une mission un peu
réduite qui arriverait après l'impact
c'est la mission Héra qui décollera je
crois en 2024 pour une arrivée en 2025
ou 2026 et voilà donc il va falloir
attendre maintenant 4 ans avant de
savoir ce qui s'est passé vraiment ouais
c'est un peu ça c'est un peu ça alors on
va on aura des nouvelles de du 7
cubitalien là je sais pas exactement ce
qui s'est passé j'aurais plus de
nouvelles dans la journée
vous aurez dans le journal de demain
et après
il y a aussi des études quand même
depuis le sol on va essayer de les
scientifiques vont vont observer les
courbes de lumière le JWST le teamsweb
spatial télescope il pourra regarder il
a regardé pendant l'impact donc je pense
que vu la la vu le visuel qu'on a depuis
le sol avec les escape d'un mètre je
pense qu'avec le James web on va avoir
des images assez fantastiques je sais
pas du tout qu'elle est quelles sont ses
capacités
de rafraîchissement si il est capable de
faire des images comme ça très très
répétés pour avoir une la dynamique de
ce de ce nuage on peut l'espérer ça sera
ça va prendre peut-être un peu plus de
temps peut-être demain en fin de journée
je sais pas combien de temps le
traitement de données
ça veut dire encore pas mal de temps
pour savoir ce qui s'est vraiment passé
on le disait normalement il y aurait dû
avoir une mission européenne c'est de
pas être annulée qui serait parti en
même temps en fait elle serait partie un
peu avant même elle serait partie en
2020 pour en arriver en 2000 ou en 2019
pour arriver en ou dans 2021 et
voilà la sonde de américaine elle
partait en 2021 pour aller en 2022 c'est
plus long
d'aller vers une cible pour se mettre en
orbite autour d'elle est-ce qu'il faut
le temps de se mettre en orbite il faut
les moins vite en fait pour il faut
accompagner la série dans sa trajectoire
donc la prochaine plus on va dire
délicatement alors que là l'objectif
c'était d'y aller franco Fred exactement
donc c'est les deux ils sont très
différents c'est un peu plus rapide on
peut le comprendre
d'y aller de pas s'arrêter de taper
dedans que de se placer autour et voilà
donc malheureusement on
leur attendre cette mission européenne
donc qui est sur les rails qui est
validé qui va décoller donc en 2024 donc
voilà on aura des nouvelles de didimo
c'est de dimorphos mais pas dans 4 ans
voilà pas tout de suite et du coup là on
a on a on a envoyé est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres tests qui sont prévus sur
d'autres astéroïdes ou alors non non
pour l'instant c'était vraiment je pense
que les scientifiques vont déjà attendre
le la mission Héra parce que le but
c'est vraiment de comprendre quelle est
la structure interne quelle est la
morphologie de chacun des deux corps
donc le la mission ira par exemple à
faire de la tomographie radar donc c'est
une technique qui consiste en gros à si
vous voulez passer le l'astéroïde au
scanner pour savoir comment il est
comment il est structuré à l'intérieur
quelle est la quantité de vide quelle
est sa densité exacte
voilà ce genre de choses et donc ce que
vous expliquer tout à l'heure sur les
billes de polystyrène pour vous donner
une image c'est c'est vraiment ça c'est
quel cratère à former le la sonde quelle
est la quantité de de déviation et
comment on peut relier les deux
paramètres pour que le jour où on
identifie un satellite potentiellement
dangereux on sache quoi faire est-ce
qu'il faut envoyer un vaisseau dix fois
plus plus gros
ce qu'il faut l'envoyer deux fois plus
vite est-ce que ça servirait est-ce
qu'il faut l'envoyer avec cinq ans
d'avance pour que la une fois de lire la
trajectoire c'est plus on le prend tôt
plus on plus on augmente l'effet si vous
voulez donc voilà c'est c'est tout ça
qui va être
qu'on va apprendre avec cette mission
après il y a il y a plein de missions
vers des astéroïdes qui sont prévues
c'est c'est vraiment un domaine en
pleine explosion on a découvert ces
dernières années vraiment des des
nouveaux mondes quoi là les images que
vous voyez typiquement à l'écran là
c'est la vision un peu old school des
astéroïdes il ressemble pas du tout du
tout à ça en fait ils sont constellés de
de rocher avec des angles très aigus
c'est vraiment des espèces de
d'amalgames de de cailloux enfin c'est
c'est c'est assez étonnant quoi
voilà je suis enthousiaste c'était
vraiment incroyable c'était magique que
je sais pas comment
check les peut-être pour le grand public
les images paraissent pas si incroyable
on est tellement habitué à voir des des
trucs dans des choses dans les films
mais ça c'est réel quoi c'est vraiment
un vaisseau qui qui a découvert ces
astéroïdes c'est impossible de voir ça
depuis le sol c'est c'est on est un
niveau de précision et de détails encore
une fois on arrive même pas à distinguer
qu'il y a deux corps depuis le sol donc
là voilà enfin c'est c'est bourrissant
comme la distance effectivement là il
est à 11 millions de kilomètres c'est on
l'a choisi parce que justement il serait
pas proche de la Terre pas loin entre
guillemets bien sûr pas loin entre
guillemets donc 11 millions de
kilomètres c'est c'est 30 fois la
distance Terre-Lune à peu près pour vous
donner une un ordre de grandeur et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a on a choisi ce
couple parce que au moment de l'impact
il serait pas loin ce qui va nous
permettre en braquant les télescopes ce
qu'on a déjà pu voir sur les images que
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure euh de
voir le panache de débris qui s'est
permet qui est complètement hallucinant
et la lumière qu'on voit faut s'imaginer
c'est pas du tout on n'est pas du tout
c'est pas la lumière d'une explosion
c'est c'est vraiment c'est juste des
cailloux je connais pas le l'albédo
exact mais ça doit être ça doit être
généralement c'est noir comme du charbon
à peu près à peu de choses près c'est
très sombre
et du coup c'est juste le reflet du
soleil sur ces bouts de charbon qu'on
voit et qui donne cette cette éclat quoi
qui est
hallucinant enfin cette image là elle
est elle est elle est incroyable on a
jamais vu quelque chose
où nous on provoqué quelque chose comme
ça et même quelque chose même
naturellement j'en ai jamais vu on peut
on peut de temps en temps voir des des
impacts météoritiques sur la sur la lune
ça fait quand même un petit flash de
lumière à la surface de la lune
on a pu voir
des des geysers sur certains certains
corps très gros
donc dépannage mais mais vraiment rien
de comparable dans cette dynamique dans
son dans son intensité dans son éclat
enfin c'est voilà par rapport enfin
voilà c'est ébouriffant alors on en a
parlé rapidement tout à l'heure mais un
astéroïde qui s'écrase sur la Terre on
en est où est-ce que c'est possible
est-ce que sur un temps est-ce qu'on
pourrait voir ça d'ici la fin notre vie
à nous d'ici ça se compte en centaines
de millions en centaines d'années en
centaines de milliers d'années alors
j'ai malheureusement je vous invite à
retrouver tous ces chiffres là sur le
site du Figaro si vous tapez menace
astéroïde
j'ai fait plusieurs articles là-dessus
pour retrouver les chiffres exacts en
fait en gros il y a il y a un rapport de
probabilité
et de taille plus un astéroïdes et gros
plus le temps plus les temps entre deux
astéroïdes sont sont longs de manière
probabiliste après
c'est de la probabilité quoi un
astéroïde qui nous frappe ça peut
arriver demain alors demain pas un corps
de quelques centaines de mètres ou de
quelques kilomètres parce que ces
astéroïdes là on les connaît en très
grande partie alors quelques centaines
de mètres on les connaît pas tous on
pourrait avoir une surprise
ça nous arrive de voir mais voilà
quelques dizaines de mètres carrément on
les connaît pas on en connaît peut-être
un faible pourcentage et ça on découvre
parfois juste avant qu'il passe à
quelques dizaines de milliers de
quelques dizaines centaines de milliers
de kilomètres de la Terre donc on n'est
pas à l'abri dans tous les cas et ça
voilà alors ça ça arrive sur terre c'est
pas à la fin de l'humanité mais mais un
astéroïde je sais pas de de 100 mètres
voilà ça peut rayer Paris de la carte si
ça tombe au milieu du Pacifique ça fait
une jolie tsunami ça fait un joli
tsunami c'est
voilà c'est c'est
un risque et ça ça peut arriver vraiment
quand je dis que c'est pas arrivé demain
c'est pas
c'est pas très probable que ça arrive
demain mais c'est possible ça arrive
demain et c'est en revanche c'est très
probable que ça arrive on va dire
dans les siècles qui viennent donc après
c'est assez dur de on a souvent cette
image là en sciences le la notion de
danger de risque le danger voilà une
falaise c'est quelque chose dangereux
mais si vous marchez à 100 mètres du
bord de la falaise le risque est faible
si vous marchez à 50 cm de la falaise le
risque est élevé
mais la falaise en soi est dangereuse
les astéroïdes c'est un peu ça la
stéroïde de les services c'est dangereux
en soi après le risque est relativement
faible la probabilité d'impact est
faible mais le danger est très grand
donc si ça arrive
voilà ce serait ça pourrait être
catastrophique et on dirait que donc
c'est c'est pour ça que
qui était inventé cette mission et qu'il
y a des organismes tout à fait sérieux
un des grands on va dire une des grandes
un des grands des grandes pistes
aujourd'hui de travail c'est
d'identifier ces astéroïdes qui
représente
un danger potentiel pour la terre et en
faire des cartographies donc ça ça dans
l'idéal ce serait bien d'avoir un
télescope spatial dédié à cette tâche
qui fasse un espèce de de relever
systématique de ce type d'objet pour
voir qu'est-ce qu'on craindrait voir
qu'est-ce qu'on voilà pour identifier
les les
dangers potentiels et évaluer mieux
évaluer le qu'aujourd'hui on évalue
plutôt en termes de probabilité donc là
jusque là voilà ça c'est pour tout ce
qui est tu risques et maintenant on l'a
vu avec ces images le but c'est
d'arriver à
une fois qu'on le voit et qu'il arrive
c'est d'arrivée de le faire dévier de
cette trajectoire comme finalement dans
les films mais c'est bien pour ça que
qu'il faut aussi coupler ça à une
mission de détection parce que si vous
détectez votre astéroïde
dans les jours qui précèdent l'impact
vous pouvez rien faire déjà vous avez
pas le temps de monter
une mission une mission
on n'a pas un vaisseau spatial en stock
qu'on puisse en vit dans une fusée comme
ça même si on avait un mettant qu'on a
un vaisseau spatial en stock un impacter
cinétique prêt à l'emploi avec sa fusée
ben voilà il faut quand même le temps de
mettre la fusée sur le bâtir de procéder
aux opérations de de la campagne de vol
etc tout ça ça prend des jours au
minimum toutes les semaines si ce n'est
des mois donc déjà il y a ce temps là
qui est incompress silence qui a le
temps de voyage et ensuite il y a le la
quoi qu'il arrive la déviation qu'on
pourra apporter reste minime on n'est
pas capable d'envoyer aujourd'hui avec
les fusées qu'on a même la fusée
superpuissante SLS de la NASA qui doit
partir à la lune même avec ce type de
lanceur on n'est pas capable d'envoyer
des charges
monstrueuses à des vitesses extrêmement
rapides donc faut forcément s'y prendre
très longtemps à l'avance et quand j'y
serai vraiment c'est des années au
minimum donc il faudrait anticiper je
sais pas mettons avec au moins 5 ans
d'avance ça laisse un ou deux ans pour
monter la mission l'impacteur puis après
trois ans elle a déviation minime qu'on
va apporter à l'astéroïde pour lui
permettre de de
s'écarter de la trajectoire dangereuse
sur sachant qu'il faut pas non plus
augmenter le danger là on l'a vu si on
pulvérise trop l'astéroïde bah voilà on
va se retrouver avec une pluie de
d'astéroïdes plutôt qu'un gros astéroïde
est-ce que c'est mieux est-ce que c'est
moins bien
ça c'est des questions qui sont qui font
l'objet de débat et qu'ils soient encore
réflexion
quoi de la part des scientifiques
voilà donc c'est bon c'est plein de
plein de questions plein de questions en
suspens et c'est pour ça qu'on a envoyé
ce test c'est pour avoir une première
idée de ben qu'est-ce qui se passe
vraiment sur un quand on balance
un vaisseau de 500 kg sur un tas de
cailloux faiblement cohésif en micro
gravité voilà qu'est-ce qui se passe
voilà et donc on a quelques réponses on
a surtout de nouvelles questions encore
plus souvent comme souvent en science
une fois qu'on a trouvé à peu près une
solution ou pas vraiment ça repose pas
mal de questions et on sera là pour les
yeux merci en tout cas Tristan d'avoir
été avec toi merci à vous d'avoir été
nombreux à nous suivre on va se passer
encore ces petites images en boucle un
petit moment et je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux live sur Figaro live